نحن موجودين في المكان الذي بدا فيه تجمع
المتظاهرين تمهيدا للتظاهر الجديد التي
ستبدا بعد حوالي ساعه
ونصف الساعه من الان ستنطلق من هنا باتجاه
الشارع لافايات المجاور في هذا الشارع
الذي تجد تشاهدونه حصلت الجريمه الثلاثيه
ظهر الجمعه اعداد كبيره من عناصر الشرطه
تتجمع هنا عند مداخل هذا الشارع
يتجمعون
للحقول دون حصول اعمال شغب جديده القياده
الكرديه في فرنسا كانت حريصه على التنسيق
مع الشرطه هذه المره كي لا يسمح لمجموعه
من المشاغبين
بي ان يندسوا في صفوف تظاهر سلميه
بطبيعتها تقول القياده الكرديه في فرنسا
ان الامر قد تجاوزنا يوم السبت الماضي
عندما حصلت الاضطرابات يعربون عن اسفهم
لما حصل يبررون ذلك بان الغضب كبير لان
القتل الثلاثه قتلوا بدم بارد على يد رجل
لم يتهم بعد بالقيام بعمل الارهاب بل ان
العمل وصف بانه عنصري وحتى الان لم يحصل
الاكراد على ما يمكن ان يؤكد لهم ان هذا
المعتدي سينال عقابه خصوصا بعد الحديث عن
وضع النفسي برر نقله الى مصحه نفسيه تابعه
لشرطي باريس طبعا الشرطه هنا تتخذ اجراءات
امنيه مكثفه كي لا يحصل ما حصل يوم السبت
الماضي عندما جرح
و30 شرطيا ومتظاهر واحد واوقف احد عشر
مثيرا للشغب الشرطه تريد تجنب ذلك من خلال
التنسيق مع القياده الكرديه التي اعطت
توجيهاتها كي تكون تظاهره اليوم هادئه لان
المطلوب ليس صداما مع الشرطه الفرنسيه
بالنظر الى ان العلاقات جيده بين الاكراد
والسلطات الفرنسيه التي اكدت على مستوى
قائد شرطه باريس لورانس ووزير العدل همم
فرنسا تقف الى جانب الاكراد وان دعمها لهم
لا يتزعزع فرنسا في عزاء كما اوضح وزير
العدل الفرنسي مشيرا اخيرا الى ان تنسيقه
بين شرطه مكافحه الارهاب من جهه والنيابه
العامه لتحديد ما اذا كان مقام به المعتدي
عملا عنصريا ام انه عمل ارهابي